STEVE: WE ARE LIVING THROUGH A
HISTORIC TURNING POINT IN
AMERICAN POLITICS THIS COUNTRY
WAS RUN BY AN ESTABLISHMENT
PARTY WITH A GLOBALIZATION TO
MAKE SURE UNCONTROLLED
IMMIGRATION AND CENTRALIZATION
OF THE ECONOMY AND IN 2016
THAT CONSENSUS WAS OVERTURNED
WITH THE REVOLUTION.
>> PAVING THE WAY FOR WHAT WE
SEE TODAY AND DEMOCRATS
LURCHED TO THE POPULACE LEFT
THAT IS DANGEROUS FOR AMERICA
BECAUSE THE MORE WE SEE THE
MORE CLEAR IT IS.
>> A DISASTER FOR THE ECONOMY
AND SOCIETY BUT UNLESS THEY
DEVELOP A POSITIVE POPULIST
AGENDA OF THEIR OWN THEY WILL
JUST BE SWEPT AWAY BECAUSE ON
ISSUE AFTER ISSUE THE POPULACE
LEFT IS IT RESPONDING AND THEY
ARE RIGHT TO BE ANGRY ABOUT
INEQUALITY.
>> BUT FOR MOST WORKING
AMERICANS INCOMES HAVE BEEN
FLAT OR FALLING SINCE THE
1970S.
>> PLUS MANY MILLIONS OF
RESPONSIBLE AMERICANS WHO WORK
HARD FIND THEMSELVES IN A
PERMANENT AND PRECARIOUS STATE
OF INSECURITY.
>> FOR EXAMPLE, A RECENT
FEDERAL RESERVE STUDY SHOWS
THEY COULDN'T SHOW AN
EXPENSIVE UNEXPECTED MEDICAL
BILLS IN RESPONSE AOC GREEN
NEW DEAL NOW BACKED BY MOST
LEADING PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATES HAS HIGH PAYING
FEDERAL JOBS TO ANYONE WHO
WANTS ONE CORY BOOKER
INTRODUCED A JOB GUARANTEE
BILL GIVING ALL AMERICANS A
SHOT AT A DAYS WORK
INTRODUCING COMPETITION TO
RAISE WAGES AND IMPROVE
BENEFITS BUT TO ESTIMATE THE
TOTAL ANNUAL COST TO BE
$500 BILLION WHO PAYS FOR IT?
THE TAXPAYER WHICH IS ALL PART
OF THE PLAN FOR THE LEFT
POPULIST.
>>.
>> ONCE YOU GET TO THE TIPPY
TOP AND THE 10 MILLION-DOLLAR
SOMETIMES YOU SEE TAX RATES AS
HIGH AS 60 OR 70 PERCENT.
STEVE: CANDIDATE CASTRO ALSO
WANTS TO REVOKE THE TRUMP TAX
CUT.
>> ABSOLUTELY I WOULD TO UNDO
THE TAX CUTS THAT BENEFITED
THE SUPER WEALTHY AND
BENEFITED CORPORATIONS.
STEVE: HE WILL NOT GET THE
PRESIDENCY BUT ELIZABETH HORN
IS PLANNING A NEW WELL PACK
THE STRUCTURAL CHANGE IS WIRE
PROPOSING AN ANNUAL TAX ON THE
RICHEST AMERICANS THEY ARE
PUNITIVE AND NOT POSITIVE THEY
HURT AMERICANS BY CUTTING OFF
INVESTMENT WITH LOWER GROWTH
AND FEWER JOBS AND THEY DON'T
MAKE THE POOR RICHER BUT HERE
IS THE KEY POLITICAL POINT AND
THEN TO HAVE THAT ALTERNATIVES
YOU HAVE WORKING AMERICANS
ECONOMIC SECURITY SO HIGHER
TAXES ON THE RICH WHAT ABOUT
LOWER TAXES?
TO SLASH PAYROLL TAXES TO
INSTITUTE A REAL LIVING WAGE
SINCE THE MINIMUM WAGE HAS NOT
BUDGED IN TEN YEARS BUT IN A
BROADER SENSE THAT VERSION
GETS WRONG IS THE SUPERFICIAL
WAY THEY APPROACH IT SO WE
SHOULD BE AIMING AT THE
UNDERLYING CAUSES IN ONE OF
THE BIGGEST IS THE FAMILY
BREAKDOWN THAT SHOWS CHILDREN
LIVING WITH A DIVORCE
SINGLE-PARENT ARE 50 PERCENT
MORE LIKELY TO BE LIVING BELOW
THE POVERTY LINE AND ANOTHER
STUDY SHOWS IN SINGLE PARENT
HOUSEHOLDS IS THE STRONGEST
NEGATIVE OF MOBILITY.
>> AND WHEN IT'S TIME THEY
STOP DENYING ON FAMILY AND
THEN THEY START LIFE ADD A
DISTINCT DISADVANTAGE THE
NEIGHBORHOOD AND THE SCHOOLS
THEY ATTEND ARE THE FOOD THAT
THEY EACH TO IMPACT THAT IN
DEVELOPMENT OR HOUSEHOLD
INCOME WHICH PLUNGES WHEN THE
FAMILY BREAKS UP HERE IS WITH
THE POPULACE LEFT GETS WRONG
ABOUT INEQUALITY.
>> THE PRICE YOU PAY FOR
OPPORTUNITY AND THEY ARE
PREPARED TO PAY THE PRICE
EVERYONE HAS ACCESS TO
OPPORTUNITY AMERICANS ARE SO
ANGRY BECAUSE THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES WITH
CONSERVATIVE POPULACE PUT THEM
BACK ON THE LADDER TO REBOOT
SOCIAL MOBILITY THAT MEANS
HELPING FAMILIES COME TOGETHER
AND STAY TOGETHER BUT OF
COURSE, IT ALSO MEANS FIXING
EDUCATION INTO MANY PARTS OF
THE COUNTRY THEY ARE BLOCKING
OPPORTUNITY INSTEAD OF
BUILDING IT.
>> 2016 CHOSE NOT ONE SINGLE
STUDENT SCORED PROFICIENT NOT
A SINGLE ONE.
>> ONE OUT OF FOUR
AFRICAN-AMERICAN STUDENTS IS
IN A SUBPAR SCHOOL.
>> BUT THAT IS TYPICALLY WHERE
THEY ARE ALREADY DOING WELL
THAT THE GAP OF STANDARDIZED
TEST SCORES AND LOW INCOME
STUDENTS HAS GROWN BY ABOUT
40 PERCENT BETWEEN 1960 AND
2007 IT IS TO HELP CHILDREN
ESCAPE FAILING SCHOOLS TO GIVE
CHOICE OF COURSE, THE PUBLIC
SECTOR UNION HATES THAT IT IS
A THREAT FOR THEIR POWER BUT
INSTEAD OF BACKING
OPPORTUNITIES TO BACK THE
UNION, HARRIS TO THOSE BIG
UNION DONORS SUCK UP
HYPOCRITES RAILING DEBT UP AND
AMBLING DOWN ON THE VERY
SYSTEM THAT PERPETUATES
INEQUALITY IN AMERICA.
>> RADICAL SCHOOL CHOICE IS
THE NEXT BIG CRUSADE AND ONE
THAT HAS THE ADVANTAGE TO BE
TRULY POPULAR WITH SUPPORT
AMONG THE LATINOS ARE
60 PERCENT WITH AFRICAN
AMERICANS BUT OUR EDUCATION
BLOCKS OPPORTUNITY BEYOND HIGH
SCHOOL ONCE AGAIN THE POPULIST
HAVE THE WRONG ANSWER.
>> WE SHOULD HAVE FREE TUITION
AT PUBLIC COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES THAT SHOULD BE A
RIGHT OF ALL AMERICANS.
STEVE: THE WORD YOU ARE
LOOKING FOR IS WRONG.
>> THAT IS WRONG TO FORCE
EVERY TAXPAYER EXPENSE INTO A
COOKIE-CUTTER FOUR YEAR
COLLEGE PROGRAM THAT WILL LAND
THEM WITH CRIPPLING DEBT THE
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE BETWEEN 16
AND 24 -YEAR-OLD IS TWICE THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE AND
ONE.$5 TRILLION IN DEBT.
>> BUT THE LEFT POPULIST
STRIKE A CHORD ON THESE ISSUES
THE CONSERVATIVE POPULACE
NEEDS A PROFIT INCENTIVE
ANSWER IT'S TIME TO RADICALLY
RETHINKING THE WHOLE SYSTEM
MAKING IT MUCH MORE OPEN AND
FLEXIBLE HELPING THEM FOCUS ON
INDIVIDUAL STRENGTHS.
>> LIKE JOBS THAT MAKE
CIVILIZED LIFE POSSIBLE GIVE
EVERY AMERICAN THE OPPORTUNITY
TO HAVE THE ECONOMY OF THE
FUTURE WITH AFFORDABLE ACCESS
AND SKILLS TRAINING FROM THE
PRIVATE SECTOR TO BUILD ON THE
GREAT START BY IF ANKE TRUMP
IF SCHOOL AND FAMILY WE HAVE
SEEN A DECADES LONG COLLAPSE
OF OPPORTUNITY FOR YES THEY
HAVE STARTED TO TURN AROUND
AND THAT IS GREAT BUT HALF A
CENTURY OF ESTABLISHMENT RULES
FOR WORKING AMERICANS IN THE
PEEL OF SOCIALISM IS NO
SURPRISE WHEN CAPITALISM FAILS
FOR GO THAT IS WHY THE
REPUBLICANS TO SIT BACK AND
HOPE THE LEFT POPULIST THE
ESTABLISHMENT IS DEAD AMERICA
IS NOT GOING BACK TO THE
COMPETENT NEVER TRUMPETERS AND
THEIR COUNTERPARTS THE FUTURE
IS POPULIST THE QUESTION IS
WHAT KIND?
NEGATIVE OR VINDICTIVE
TOP-DOWN AUTHORITARIANISM OF
THE LEFT OR A POSITIVE PEOPLE
POWERED VERSION ON THE RIGHT?
PRO WORKER PRO COMMUNITY.